[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le débat nous
parlerons ce soir de l'état d'urgence
avec cette question faut-il le prolonger
alors depuis les attentats du 13
novembre 2015 l'état d'urgence a été
reconduit quatre fois il doit
normalement s'achever à la fin du mois
de janvier prochain
s'il n'y a pas de modifications suite à
la démission du premier ministre
ce régime d'exception à semble-t-il été
efficace au lendemain des attentats pour
accélérer la traque des terroristes mais
depuis de nombreuses voix s'élèvent pour
dire qu'il s'essouffle et qu'un retour à
la normale est plus qu'indispensable
avec nous pour en débattre pascalou evil
yom vous êtes secrétaire national de
l'union syndicale des magistrats
pictures julien leucan vous êtes
secrétaire régional adjoint du syndicat
alliance police nationale
bonsoir à tous les deux je commencerai
avec vous parce qu à louisville yum
l'ancien premier ministre manuel valls
donc a récemment déclaré qu'il pensait
prolonger l'état d'urgence jusqu'aux
élections présidentielles est ce une
justification valable selon vous alors
si la justification c'est parce que il
ya les élections présidentielles ça
semble un peu court il faut que l'état
d'urgence soit bien sûr justifié dans
des conditions très précises
il faut un péril imminent ce qui bien
sûr a été le cas lorsque bien sûr les
attentats sont survenus et c'est
d'ailleurs après les attentats
immédiatement après que l'état d'urgence
a été d'abord prononcé puis prolongé
donc le simple fait je dirais qu de
rentrer en campagne présidentielle n'est
pas en soi un critère suffisant pour
prolonger l'état d'urgence après bien
sûr il peut y avoir d'autres
explications d'autres motifs mais en
tout cas celui là n'est pas suffisant
julien le calme
de votre côté qu'est ce que l'état
d'urgence a changé dans votre pratique
de policiers sur le terrain
alors effectivement au début ça a donné
plusieurs droits supplémentaires aux
policiers notamment de pouvoir porter
son arme
hors service lors de ses congés voilà
qui était une manière de se protéger soi
et protéger les citoyens dans ses
différents déplacements
ça apporte également des moyens de
contrôles supplémentaires des droits de
contrôle supplémentaires les
perquisitions administrative de nuit
également voilà et c'est quelque chose
qui a été efficace dans un premier temps
ça vous a permis d'être voilà d'avoir
tous de résultats pudiquement le mois
qui a suivi les attentats
ces perquisitions administratives ont
permis de voile et d'interpeller
plusieurs individus mais effectivement
ça a perdu de sa de son effet de
surprise dans le temps et de son
efficacité
donc c'est pas forcément pour vous une
solution de reconduire l'état d'urgence
pas forcément le terrorisme est devenu
une menace une menace permanente
donc effectivement nous en tant que
policier pour lutter face contre le
terrorisme il nous faudrait des moyens
matériels supplémentaires mais surtout
des moyens humains parce que suite aux
événements tragiques du mois de novembre
effectivement les services de
renseignement étaient renforcés de 800
fonctionnaires policiers
sauf que ces 800 fonctionnaires ont été
pris dans les services publics
deux commissariats donc si vous voulez
nous on a un manque criant de personnel
dans les commissariats donc oui pour la
reconduction mais avec plus de moyens
rester efficace sur de tout faire pour
que nos téléspectateurs comprennent bien
pascal auvé yom ce que vous dénoncez en
fait c'est ce transfert donc de
prérogatives judiciaires entre les mains
des pouvoirs administratifs c'est là le
point crispant pour vous c'était en état
d'urgence
et d'ailleurs ça a été le cas de ses
doigts c'est plus le juge judiciaire qui
contrôle les atteintes aux libertés
alors que la liberté individuelle
elle est bien sûr protégé par le juge
judiciaire donc c'est plus le cas on est
dans un régime encore une fois
d'exception on est dans un régime qui
doit être et doit rester provisoire tout
le monde est d'accord sur le fait de qui
doit rester provisoire le président de
la république lui-même le disait encore
au matin du 14 juillet et bien entendu
il la nature même d'un état d'un état
d'urgence comme d'un état d'exception
c'est d'avoir des pouvoirs exorbitants
pendant une période limitée après ce qui
est important c'est de pouvoir trouver
une transition alors cette transition
comment on la trouve
on la trouve notamment en changeant la
législation ça a déjà été le cas puisque
au mois de juin on a voté une loi
renforçant les dispositifs en matière de
lutte contre la grande criminalité et le
terrorisme et on a également lors de la
dernière prolongation de l'état
d'urgence lé 21 juillet encore accrue
des dispositifs en matière de répression
du terrorisme
donc je marchais bien je suis important
de petits chiffres pour rappeler donc
l'état d'urgence c'est quand même 4000
perquisition administrative 400
assignation est une vingtaine de
mosquées et de lieux de prières fermé
c'est un peu le résultat de 2,77 à
d'urgence de crépitement quelle
transition trouvé c'est là la question
pour vous voilà parce que la transition
de toute façon elle a déjà eu lieu
puisque en parallèle de ce que vous
venez d'évoquer la cire des des mesures
administratives qui ne sont que de la
mesure administrative celle qui donne
pas forcément lieu automatiquement
ensuite à des poursuites judiciaires ça
a été le cas pour effectivement quelques
centaines d'affaires mais ça n'a pas été
le cas systématiquement mais en
parallèle de sa de toute façon il y a
bien sûr le rôle
et le rôle du parquet du procureur qui
lui a pu mener des enquêtes
il faut savoir qu'actuellement il ya
mille personnes qui font l'objet d'
enquête au sein du parquet
antiterroriste de paris
là où il y avait à peine une vingtaine
d'affaires en 2013
c'est pour donner quand même un ordre
d'idée sur l'accroissement à la fois des
techniques dans quête des moyens et des
investigations qui ont permis
effectivement de d'enquêté et qu'ils
font est actuellement de deux procédures
qui sont en cours ça vous donne du
travail eux en plus aussi avoué qu'il y
avait les moyens nécessaires mais bon
voilà il ya énormément de travail pour
le juge en a déjà beaucoup et y en a de
plus en plus alors les moyens je rejoins
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
à dire que il faut de toute façon
renforcer les moyens
quoi qu'il en soit c'est le cas pour la
police et des services enquêteurs c'est
le cas pour les services de
renseignement également et c'est le cas
aussi bien sûr qu'on est pour les
magistrats
donc c'était un petit peu le cas on va
dire pour les magistrats antiterroristes
qui voient leur nombre un petit peu
augmenté
néanmoins il faut savoir que le nombre
de magistrats en france restent encore
largement insuffisant pour juger toutes
les affaires
manque plus de 500 magistrats au minimum
mais certaines évaluations vont même
fixent eux mêmes à peu près à 1000 le
nombre de magistrats qui font encore
renommée et vous vous êtes fait entendre
sur cette question vous avez des
réponses
on commence en avoir c'est à dire qu'on
a actuellement mise de la justice qui
est plus favorable bien sûr à
l'augmentation des recrutements mais il
faut de toute façon et quels que soient
les gouvernements qui vont suivre
il faut envisager une loi pluriannuelle
un peu comme pour les services de police
d'ailleurs c'est à dire des recrutements
pérenne sur plusieurs années parce que
le temps que les personnes ayant
formation pour un magistrat il faut
compter 30 mois à peu près de formation
voyez donc c'est très très long avant de
recruter quelqu'un et qui soit vraiment
sur le terrain et
et performant julien le cam si jamais
l'état d'urgence n'est pas reconduit
qu'est-ce que ça va changer pour vous si
vous voulez si l'état d'urgence mon nous
je sais qu'on a des réquisitions tous
les jours la part du procureur qui nous
autorise à contrôler les individus en
tous lieux c'est vrai que ça changerait
sa restant au niveau des contrôles
d'identité par exemple qu'on pourrait
plus se permettre de contrôler les
identités des gens voient la com com
actuellement sous les eaux il y aura une
restriction on retomberait dans le cadre
on va dire normal du contrôle d'identité
alors que la actuellement mes collègues
peuvent contrôler sur l'ensemble d'une
commune les bagages et personnes les
contrôler les identités grâce aux
réquisitions du procureur voilà donc en
fait on reviendrait un système classique
on doit repasser par le juge parle par
le procureur oui voilà alors tous savent
surtout new skies
si l'état d'urgence venait à disparaître
ça permettrait d'annuler beaucoup de
servitude qu'on a depuis justement la
mise en place de l'état d'urgence il
faut savoir que des personnalités
politiques sont gardés par des
fonctionnaires de la sécurité publique
actuellement dans 78 donc ça fait
plusieurs fonctionnaires il y en faut
compter à peu près huit fonctionnaires
par exemple qui sont mobilisés pour la
garde par exemple de monsieur larcher de
madame marine le pen c'est des
patrouilles en moins sur la voie
publique donc c'est des fonctionnaires
qu'on aurait en plus pour sécuriser
voilà la voie publique ça permettrait
effectivement de recentrer un peu
certains policiers dans leur coeur de
métier tout à fait sûrs un point sur les
libertés vous l'avez évoqué avec les
contrôles d'identité et c'est un point
qui vous qui vous importent beaucoup
mais est ce que on est dans une
entraves à l'état de droit on n'irait
pas jusqu'à dire cela par rapport à
l'état d'urgence mais ça va parler
d'ailleurs on peut pas dire qu'on est
dans une entra dans le sens où la loi
bien sûr fixe quand même des cadres
heureusement donc elle a fixé notamment
le fait que le juge administratif peut
contrôler une fois que les mesures sont
prises
pas avant c'est la grande différence
parce que en matière judiciaire le juge
il autorise les mesures alors que là
dans l'état d'urgence le juge
administratif n'intervient que si on lui
demande
mais une fois que la mesure a été prise
par exemple une fois que la perquisition
a été réalisée une fois que la personne
est assigné à résidence
donc il ya quand même un contrôle d'un
juge mais qui n'est pas judiciaire que
les juges administratifs
donc il ya effectivement des garde-fous
néanmoins il est vrai que les garde-fous
ne sont pas forcément comme une fois les
mêmes et interviennent pas au même stade
je voulais juste rajouter quand même
tout à l'heure par rapport à ce que vous
disiez sur les contrôles d'identité
c'est que la loi du 3 juin quand même
largement renforcé les pouvoirs du
procureur en matière à la fois de
contrôler l'identité mais aussi en
matière de fouilles de bagages et de
fouilles de véhicules
il ya quand même un an un nombre de
pouvoir maintenant beaucoup plus
importants qui sont donnés au parquet
pour pouvoir intervenir là où avant
effectivement il ne pouvait pas
forcément de le faire il ya aussi
d'autres mesures qui se peuvent être
prises par exemple d assignation à
résidence
deux personnes revenant de théâtre
d'opérations terreur des ac depuis
juillet revoilà donc ça c'est des
possibilités qui existent maintenant
et puis encore une fois la politique
pénale du parquet de paris ou du parquet
antiterroriste de paris s'est elle
énormément aussi durci notamment depuis
l'été là où auparavant
certaines personnes n'avaient pas
forcément n'est pas forcément
systématiquement poursuivis lorsqu'elle
revenait par exemple de syrie ou d'irak
désormais elles le sont presque
systématiquement et surtout elles le
sont maintenant sur la base d'une
infraction de nature criminelle
donc avec des peines encourues qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à 30 ans de
réclusion criminelle pour enchaîner
justement sur cette question d
assignation un exemple une question pour
vous deux est ce que c'est réellement
efficace l'état d'urgence contre le
terrorisme sachant que je reprendrai cet
exemple de l'assassinât du prêtre
normand qui donc un des deux tueurs
était lui-même assigné à résidence il
avait le droit de sortir le matin entre
8h30 et 10h30 je crois il a profité de
cette autorisation pour aller commettre
son crime et il revenait justement de
syrie donc c'est là on voit les limites
de cet état d'urgence 8 je pense que de
toute façon ça serait mentir aux
français que de leur faire croire que
tout système serait enfin ce système
serait infaillible etc l'état d'urgence
permettrait de résoudre et d'éviter
effectivement toute difficulté on a
malheureusement bien vu que après
l'attentât du bataclan et l'état
d'urgence se sont déroulés hélas
d'autres attentats que ça soit
effectivement au domicile de policiers à
magnanville ça soit dans une église à
saint-etienne du rouvray l'attentât
effectivement sur la promenade des
anglais de nice donc on est
effectivement malheureusement dans un
processus où ce qu'il faut c'est pouvoir
prévenir le plus vite possible le
passage à l'acte trouvait effectivement
les éléments d'informations pour pouvoir
déjouer des attentats c'est ce qui c'est
ce qui permet alors encore une fois la
justice maintenant elle peut le faire
parce que il ya des infractions
maintenant qui permettent même de
d'incriminer des actes préparatoires ça
s'appelle l'entreprise le terroriste
individuel ou l'association de
malfaiteurs en vue d'une entreprise
terroriste ou là on n'est que sur les
actes préparatoires et on entend
d'ailleurs bien que
il ya eu plusieurs attentats déjoués ces
derniers mois évidemment il faut
continuer dans ce processus
je viens le cam de votre côté sur cette
question de l'efficacité par mois et
nous mais c'est simple on a un manque
criant d'effectifs sur les 78 joueurs
pour mes collègues du renseignement on a
un déficit de personnel énorme
c'est à dire qu'on a même un déficit de
moyens moi j'ai mes collègues qui me
disent qu'ils n'ont pas assez de
véhicules pour se rendre sur leur lieu
de rendez vous pour avoir des contacts
ils seront obligés d'annuler certaines
missions parce qu'il manque de véhicules
donc voyez quand on en est à ce niveau
là nous il nous manque 300
fonctionnaires sur le département des
yvelines
actuellement on est en train de fermer
des commissariats dans les yvelines
donc en termes de lutte contre le
terrorisme on a vu mieux c'est vrai que
nous on est très inquiet parce que
malgré tout depuis novembre 2015 dans le
78 nous perdons régulièrement beaucoup
d'effectifs
là on va déjà on va passer sous la barre
des 1900 fonctionnaires sur le
département ce qui s'est jamais vu c'est
très inquiétant et on voit que les
sorties d'école qui n'arrive ne comble
même pas de moitié les départs
contraints
françois hollande avait dit qu il
qu'il y aurait des recrues d'école
justement cette fois ci su ce que pour
les magistrats c'est vrai que la
formation est très longue
la mise en place de l'organisation des
concours en la mise en place de la
formation qui dure un an avec les stages
donc effectivement avant de peut-être
ressentir ses bienfaits il faudra un
moment
enfin mon avis un grand moment mais pour
l'instant nous on perd beaucoup
d'effectivement le 78 donc en termes de
lutte contre le terrorisme
effectivement on n'est pas dans le
meilleur position très bien on est
obligé de s'arrêter là merci à vous
d'avoir participé à ce débat et nous
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle édition de 7,8 le
débat merci de nous avoir suivis
[Musique]